[Music]
brandon is with us brandon is in cool
springs
colorado springs i'm sorry colorado hey
brandon how are you
i'm doing great mr ramsey dr john thank
you so much for taking my call sure
what's up
yeah uh just calling to see if i can
kind of do a little bit of a suzie orman
thing with you uh i have uh
dave ramsey thing yeah
yeah sort of uh does it fit into the
ramsey plan here we're looking to
purchase a home
uh in the mountains it's going to be a
vacation home kind of near one of my ski
resorts i love going to cool
you got the money um so we're looking
i'm so sorry do you have the cash
uh
oh to purchase it cash yes
uh no but we do have a down payment yeah
i wouldn't do it
a second a second home is a toy
and you pay cash for toys if you want to
be wealthy
i've got a lake house i'm heading to
this afternoon when i get off the air
and i paid cash for it a long long time
ago and then i rebuilt another one on
the same property and paid cash for that
and i absolutely love it
i would have 23 years later hated the
stinking thing uh however if i had been
paying payments on it as much as it sits
empty
and it's just you're just not ready to
buy a second home you don't need to be
doing vacation homes when you don't have
the money to pay for them what do you
tell somebody dave that has this
imaginary spreadsheet with all of the
airbnb
guests they're going to have to float it
all and all the it becomes this funny
math where we talked about this earlier
here's the thing
using debt to do stuff like this
only works when it works
and nothing ever works
in life the way you think it's going to
never you know never the best laid plans
of mice and men you just you just you
know you can project this this yellow
brick road experience
and then you'll run into the wicked
witch every time and and the flying
monkeys
and uh those little those little oompa
loompa guys look like poodles with the
curved swords
remember them yeah you're going to run
into all these things along the way the
yellow brick road is fraught with danger
that's right including stupid
strongmen that have no brain
they're out there everywhere and you
know this is what you run into so this
stuff only works if it works and nothing
ever goes exactly as planned
and the beautiful thing is when you're
on a bunch of rental property and
you don't have any payments and there's
a pandemic or something
and some of your tenants can't pay
um because they lost their jobs it's not
their fault
uh you can grant mercy
um but when you have payments
you're the one needing mercy that's
right
and but but but those tenants will pay
off that rental property for you you
heard that crap see that's what that's
that yellow brick road thing you left
out the flying monkey yep you know you
left out the pandemic you left out the
big bad wolf i'm gonna mix up a bunch of
different stories here together in this
metaphor but you know but you see what
i'm saying and that that's the problem
is um
that that uh
it happens every time too it does every
time
life is predictable life is happening
it's gonna happen i've never thought of
a vacation home i love the way it's a
toy yeah it's a toy it's fun especially
if you want to buy a four-wheeler a
motorcycle a boat it's a toy yep you
know but if you got to put payments on
it that just means you're too broke to
have it that's right yeah and because
this you know i added up when i was
broke
because i'm a water skier i love the
lake i love the i love the mountains too
like he does i'd love to have i don't
have a ski house but i wouldn't mind
having one they're wonderful and um
but i added up one time when i had
payments on a boat when i first started
doing this stuff about 30 years ago um
that i well it's longer actually longer
than that i go but i added up with the
payments i was making on the boat the
insurance on the boat
what it cost me per minute to ski
i averaged out that i was going to ski
this many times a year and i would ski
10 minutes this run i'd ski 5 minutes
that run i skied 15 minutes that run and
i added it up and uh a buddy of mine
started telling me about how he needed a
better bass boat and so i added up per
pound what the bass was costing him
and it was something like 14 000 a pound
you know or something i mean it was like
okay so hey that brings that's a good
ques a good question then how do you
decide so if this guy is going to try to
buy a ski house that he likes and he
goes and visits it seven times a year
which would be a lot of ski trips you
cannot get you cannot financially
justify it so it only time is justified
is when it's you've got the cash in hand
it's not you're not it's not financially
justified and it's not about investment
it's about it it's about not harming my
life there you go because it does not
make sense it's a lifestyle choice okay
you know you've been to my lake house
okay so if you say
i mean that one makes sense that's a
pretty cool house it's a beautiful home
and it's a great investment it's gone up
in value that's fine but you know the
number of hours we spend there the
number of weekends we spend there the
amount of time we spend on the water
you know could we not rent an airbnb on
the lake
and come out millions of dollars ahead
absolutely we could
but we've got the money
and it doesn't
hurt our financial situation because
we're not paying payments on it
and so but when you you you know you've
got to look at because it truly is a toy
you know you cannot justify i love that
idea you can't financially justify these
things at all none of them uh they don't
make sense um
and so you know with what you spend on a
vacation home how many times can you
know you can rent a
just outside colorado springs i've done
it you can rent the uh
15 000 square foot
mansion
on the side of a mountain ski and ski
out for thirty thousand bucks a week
thirty thousand bucks a week right okay
and if you go four weeks a year okay
let's see that's 120 000 bucks right
and so how long does it take you to get
to 5 million bucks
that's a lot of weeks you know you
cannot financially justify it you can't
financially justify it but but if you've
if you've got 100 million dollars and
you want to drop 5 million in that thing
it's a toy
and you can afford it then it doesn't
matter that it doesn't financially work
it's a place that's yours it's your
families it's memory you know the
difference between a 5 000 car and a 25
000 car you can't justify it financially
but if you can afford it it's okay to
take that bit of a luxury there you go
you know it's the same kind of a thing
because both of them will get you from
point a to point b so shut up stop your
whining right and both of them probably
got air conditioning so shut up and stop
your whining and both of them are
somewhat reliable so shut up and stop
your whining so the difference in a 5000
car twenty five thousand dollar car is a
want right
and and it's okay well i'm not against
once on this show but you have to pay
cash for them
uh and you it because the upgrades are
luxury there you go it's living like no
one else so later you can live and give
like no one else so put yourself in that
position is what i would do i love that
dave i love it
that's the direction to go and i want
you to get a vacation house i'm not i'm
not saying i'm doing something and
telling you you shouldn't
but i didn't the first property again
you've been down there we'd at our
uh personalities retreat down there
but the first one i bought was 103 000.
it was one tiny little lot off to the
right-hand side of that property and it
was this little bitty brick house from
1974 on it and we
had a boat dock all i care about was a
boat dock and a place to sleep that's
all i cared about and a place to put the
boat and you know have fun and ski the
kids and tube the kids and all that
stuff and the kids were tiny
and
you know now all these years later we
bought several properties adjacent uh
did some tear downs some rebuilds built
a nice big home on there now
and uh and you know all the grandkids
saw seven of them and all the maybe 14
15 people the ramsey clan down there
this weekend you know for labor day
weekend right so but you you we worked
up to that over 25 years
and we paid cash for it and at no point
was it a big percentage of our world
including so it was never a burden it
was only fun right yeah and because it
just takes the fun out of it
and also it gets it gets you in the land
of stupid real quick oh yeah and then it
gets to the land of justification and
then all of a sudden yeah one glitch one
one flying monkey and the whole thing
comes down yeah if you gotta if you got
the down payment only hon just go rent
yeah just go rent it three times a year
and until you've got the money and when
you got the money buy
this is the ramsey show